nuestro objetivo será utilizar los
potenciales de reducción estándar que se
muestran abajo para calcular la
constante de equilibrio verdad y esta
constante de equilibrio es de la que
hablamos en el vídeo anterior verdad y
que denotamos con la letra k muy bien
entonces queremos calcular la constante
de equilibrio para la siguiente reacción
a 25 grados centígrados y nos referimos
justamente a esta reacción de tipo redox
que tenemos aquí así que en el vídeo
anterior hablamos de la relación que
existe entre el potencial de celda
estándar verdad que denotamos con la
letra es verdad ponemos como es 0
hablamos de la relación que hay entre 0
y la constante de equilibrio k muy bien
así que si podemos calcular que es 0 el
valor de 0 entonces podemos calcular
inmediatamente o al menos haciendo
algunos trucos algebraicos podemos
calcular la constante de equilibrio acá
y de hecho ya sabemos cómo calcular el
potencial de es el de estándar verdad
así que veamos primero ésta
sé mi reacción que tenemos aquí abajo en
donde nos dicen que tenemos yodo sólido
verdad al cual le estamos agregando 2
electrones para convertirlo en un en
unión de yodo 2 y menos verdad tenemos
dos iones de yodo y menos muy bien y
está semi reacción tiene un potencial de
reducción estándar de 0.54 volts
positivos muy bien así que de hecho
podemos ver que exactamente eso es lo
que está pasando en nuestra reacción
redox verdad tenemos yodo sólido que
está convirtiéndose en iones de yodo
verdad y - así que justamente nos vamos
a quedar con esta reacción que es de o
está semi reacción que es de reducción
muy bien ahora bien pensemos que es lo
que está pasando con el aluminio en la
reacción original vemos que el aluminio
está perdiendo electrones verdad porque
se está convirtiendo en aluminio 3
positivo y en cambio aquí tenemos la
reacción contraria así que de hecho ésta
está escrita digamos como una semi
reacción
y lo que tenemos que hacer es revertir
la así que si le escribimos al revés
tendríamos aluminio sólido verdad nos
produce iones de aluminio 3 positivo por
supuesto esto en solución acuosa y
además nos genera 3 electrones es decir
estamos pensando que el aluminio está
perdiendo 3 electrones verdad entonces
podemos concluir que esta es una semi
reacción de oxidación ahora bien si
pensamos en el potencial digamos de esta
semi reacción entonces estaríamos
pensando en el potencial de oxidación
verdad esto simplemente como invertimos
la reacción será cambiarle el signo a
este valor del potencial de reducción
estándar que teníamos originalmente
verdad entonces tendremos 1.66 volts
positivos cierto entonces si pensamos en
la reacción que teníamos aquí en la semi
reacción de reducción tendremos un
potencial de reducción estándar de
0.54 volts y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es balancear estas dos ecuaciones
la primera que tenemos es más quizás
debería eliminar esta que tengo a la
mitad para no confundirnos ok vamos a
eliminar esta reacción sólo se mi
reacción sólo para no confundirnos
entonces esta semi reacción de reducción
y esta semi reacción de oxidación
tenemos que balancear la y tenemos que
balancear la en el sentido de que
tenemos que tener la misma cantidad de
electrones verdad tenemos que pensar que
todos los electrones que pierde uno de
estos elementos los gana el otro muy
bien entonces de este lado de este lado
tenemos los electrones verdad mientras
que de este lado en esta otra semi
reacción tenemos tres electrones así que
tenemos que balancear lo digamos
obteniendo seis electrones para cada una
de estas semi reacciones así que la
primera de ellas la podemos multiplicar
por tres verdad multiplicamos por tres
esta semi reacción y así obtendremos
seis electrones
mientras que la segunda semi reacción la
segunda semi reacción para obtener 6
electrones podemos multiplicar la por 2
muy bien así que vamos vamos a
reescribir estas nuevas semi reacciones
vamos a reescribir las digamos esta
sería la semi reacción de reducción y
tendríamos tres y dos sólido por
supuesto más ahora tendremos tres por
dos son seis electrones verdad que nos
producen seis y menos en solución acuosa
muy bien y si pensamos ahora en el
potencial de reducción estándar para
esta reacción tenemos que recordar que
que es una propiedad intensiva verdad
así que en realidad ésta no se
multiplica verdad no tenemos que
multiplicar por tres al 0.54 que ya
teníamos acá verdad entonces se queda
simplemente igual 0.54 volts ahora si
nos fijamos en la reacción de oxidación
verdad que sería multiplicar esta
reacción por 2
2 aluminio en estado sólido nos produce
2 aluminio 3 positivo en solución acuosa
+ 6 electrones verdad y nuevamente el
potencial el potencial de oxidación es
una propiedad intensiva así que no lo
multiplicamos nos quedamos con 1.66
volts y ahora encontramos la reacción
total vamos a encontrar la reacción
total que sería simplemente como si
sumáramos o más bien vamos a sumar estas
dos reacciones verdad para encontrar
digamos la reacción total entonces por
supuesto todo lo que hicimos de
multiplicar estas reacciones o semi
reacciones era para cancelar los
electrones muy bien entonces si
agregamos verdad tendremos estos dos que
serían nuestros reactivos tendríamos 3 y
2 s + 2
aluminio y como productos tendríamos
estos dos verdad tendríamos estos dos
entonces tendríamos seis y menos en
solución acuosa más 2 a el 3 más también
en solución acuosa muy bien entonces si
nos fijamos bien en estas en esta
reacción verdad es justamente la
reacción original que teníamos al inicio
del ejercicio verdad teníamos 3 y 2 más
2 a l que es justamente lo que tenemos
del lado de los reactivos y del lado de
los productos tenemos seis y menos más
dos a l tres más que es justamente lo
que tenemos aquí abajo muy bien ahora
hay que recordar porque hicimos todo
esto en realidad todo esto lo hicimos
porque queremos calcular el potencial de
ese es el de estándar para después
calcular la constante de equilibrio acá
muy bien y lo que sí sabemos es cómo
calcular el potencial de celda estándar
el potencial de es el de estándar
es la suma del potencial estándar de
reducción más el potencial de oxidación
estándar muy bien entonces estos valores
se encuentran justamente aquí ya los
tenemos el primero de ellos es 0.54
positivo y el segundo de ellos es 1.66
66 vamos a omitir por ahora el la letra
b de volts muy bien y entonces
concluimos que el potencial de celda
estándar es justamente bueno si sumamos
esto nos da 2.20 volts muy bien dos
puntos 20 volts y ahora podemos digamos
utilizar alguna ecuación que nos
relacione el potencial de es el de
estándar con la constante de equilibrio
acá y de hecho esa la vimos en el vídeo
anterior verdad la ecuación que la
relación es la siguiente que voy a
escribir que nos dice que el potencial
estándar
justamente 0.05 92 volts dividido entre
el número de moles n verdad por supuesto
esta n recordemos quienes n es el número
de moles de electrones transferidos en
la reacción redox verdad entonces si nos
fijamos aquí tendremos que coincide
justamente con que son 6 electrones 6
moles de electrones verdad así que
sabremos cómo calcular eso y luego hay
que multiplicar por el logaritmo de
nuestra constante de equilibrio k muy
bien así que lo único que tenemos que
hacer aquí es sustituir los valores que
ya conocemos es 0 y n y después despejar
la letra k muy bien entonces es 0 ya lo
tenemos justamente es 2.20 bolsas y que
lo podemos digamos poner en esta
ecuación vamos a hacer eso y tendremos
punto 20 volts será igual a 0.05 92 me
falta 12 volts dividido entre el número
de moles de electrones transferidos que
era 6 cierto y esto multiplica al
logaritmo de nuestra constante de
equilibrio así que lo único que tenemos
que hacer aquí es empezar a resolver y
vamos a hacer esto sacando la
calculadora verdad lo único que tenemos
que hacer es lo siguiente así que vamos
a hacer estas operaciones verdad 2.20
hay que multiplicarlo por 6 y luego hay
que dividirlo entre 0.05 92 verdad
0.0
592 y eso nos da como respuesta bueno
esto que está en fracciones y que en
decimales son 222 puntos 97 que vamos a
redondear lo como 223 muy bien entonces
esto será 200 vamos a ponerlo con
amarillo 223 será igual al logaritmo al
logaritmo vamos a ponerlo con rojo al
logaritmo de nuestra constante de
equilibrio así que para que digamos para
cancelar el logaritmo tenemos que poner
como base 10 y elevar simplemente
elevamos 10 a la digamos 223 del lado
izquierdo y logaritmo de acá del lado
derecho así que estos justamente lo que
hace es que se cancelen y tendremos que
nuestra constante de equilibrio será 10
elevado a la 223 que obviamente es un
número gigantesco verdad es sorprendente
porque además sólo tenemos 2.20 volts
como nuestro potencial de celda estándar
lo cual no da mucho pie para que
tengamos una
acción inversa verdad justamente esta es
la reacción en nuestra reacción original
tenemos solo esta flecha verdad y este
es digamos una de las consecuencias de
este número muy grande